also we got gifts that we gotta open
this for me dude yes these are gifts
that we bought each other right yes yes
when we know what they are yeah
and enjoy that yes i know what that is
where were you when you bought this well
i guess you can't tell me because it
would it would ruin it yeah yeah are you
excited that i'm gonna open this because
you know exactly what it is yeah i know
exactly what it is i remember buying it
at adamandeve.com i mean all right first
gift that's from cody that was purchased
for me by cody is is there it is dude
hope you like it this is a harry potter
scarf it's a harry potter scarf yep it's
a duke it's uh
was i supposed to give this to you
i think i'm supposed to just kidding i
opened my gift to you
no dude i got this for you man no i
think
it's a duke scarf
i hope you like it candace asked the
producers who
was supposed to give what
uh yeah dude yeah dude i hope you like
it man that's the school that i went to
yeah no that's really cool man yeah
i guess i went there too
yeah well yeah duke more like puke am i
right okay give it back
that's not funny
oh man okay i can't wait to open my gift
yeah
oh
what's this thing
what oh that one it was a nice get a
little respect i'm saving it for later
okay nice wrap job thanks man thank you
what is this
it feels like some kind of book
you know i love books i knew you'd like
that one show them yeah how i built this
by guy rez
i knew you'd like that one i actually am
[ __ ] stoked right now
seriously this is sick
thank you so much no problem dude yeah
[Laughter]
thanks dude
thanks man
damn all right open your next one
all right i remember that one
oh you're gonna love it
it's a dog it's a dog calendar oh
wow
yeah dude thank you
thank you for the wow
for this records
yeah there you go finals this is a black
soprano family
uh vinyl yep this is benny the butcher
and yep all those boys i knew you're a
big fan yeah so and the sean price and
phases um
this is the ep damn lane of the crooks
yeah about that thank you man yeah
absolutely i wanted to pull a little um
uh nardwar yeah get you some record
thank you
so thank you man yeah
all right thanks no problem
no problem yeah no problem dude
i'm like oh this feels like
it might help me out right now
yeah that's um jelqing fluid
oh the [ __ ] is this well what's that
supposed to mean that was my idea um
i actually didn't brush my teeth this
morning
so this is actually just this morning
i was honestly thinking on the way here
i was like damn i forgot to brush my
teeth
what if my breath just smells horrible i
was like maybe i should ask someone for
some gum yeah well you don't need and we
got let's rain here let's just do us all
a favor and keep that in the car
keep that in the bunk
you wouldn't mind just using that every
single time
[Laughter]
to the head wrote down
you gonna swallow it
you're a sick [ __ ]
do it do it dude no you are not you're
not just going to spit that [ __ ] on the
floor
well there's cups behind you
with the champagne bottle put it in here
spin it in your over and shoot
reverse chewy
oh man just throwing up in a shoe and
just
leave me outside
oh you got me joking fluid as well yes i
did what the [ __ ] no that is i got you
is this a
deer urine
is this like dough like you sprinkle
this for hunting canadian maple syrup oh
this is canadian maple syrup it's maybe
yeah
eskimo neck from canada
oh i thought this was deer piss to go
hunting with
oh feels like it might be another book
this one's how to jelk
you know it says your name right here
yeah
no well
what does it say to the left to say
jolly joey this is joey noel
just dudes names yeah steve
eric
nathan
thanks man yeah yeah yeah yeah hardcover
green lights hard cover of green lights
i know you got the kindle and then the
audiobook
so i didn't have the hardcover i had the
soft one i want you to complete the quad
the quadruple quadrilogy thanks man yeah
no problem dude
[Laughter]
let's see i think
didn't we already buy this
yeah but it
it's nice to have two
i can take it
no i want it okay all right i want two
that's fine let me read a little excerpt
you wanna do a little secret santa right
now
if you're not a starter and you think
you should be
give him no choice in the decision
play so well it's undeniable
no you have that one for free yes it's
illegal
oh you're yeah you're re-streaming yeah
yeah
yeah we're gonna get sued damn common
sense is like money and health once you
have it you have to work to keep it well
no here we go one more some people look
for an excuse to do
others look for an excuse not to
okay that's about it for that
doesn't that sound like a like a poster
on a teacher's wall yeah like you can go
into your principal's office yeah and
yes that goes around a vague horizon
with a couple walking walking towards it
yeah
some people with a conceal on the page
yeah
some people strive to do math others
just make it
what this next gift
which you definitely bought it's smaller
it's a small little box
oh my god cody is this a ring
old world christmas
yep it's a christmas ornament that is a
puffer fish oh my god
yeah it is yeah it's a special
look at that yeah and the you the mouth
you can actually jam carrots jam carrots
yeah the mouth is open
[Laughter]
that's hilarious yeah this is this is
genius yeah well yeah great gift thank
you yeah
i'm gonna sprinkle some deer urine on it
let's see what else you got me here uh
that's the college i went to
is it yep open it up okay
what do we got here
oh that is a max verstappen flag
burn that throw it behind you max
verstappen here let me see that let me
see that winner
of f1 and my king let me see that
yeah
you're not a max fan
no i'm just a fan of winners dude sorry
all right this is a medium-sized box
huh would you call this medium
uh yeah that's a schmedium
[Laughter]
yes that actually was my idea thank you
dude yeah
cody got me a remote control car
which i'm gonna
put that sucker open yeah i'm gonna do
this for the rest of the yeah episodes
it's me talking to you
uh-huh uh-huh hey shut up shut up
shut up
[Music]
that's actually sick and i see that no
it's my gift i still have three more
yeah i got you three more jesus
i'm really splurged this year dude you
spoil me i'm a i'm a giver dude
all right oh let's [ __ ] go
wax
surf wax yeah you got me sticky bombs
dude that's for you
and
and
another max verstappen flag
max verstappen beach towel yeah max burp
app first yeah max burban yeah go with
that one max bird batman max verstappen
no this is the college i went to
oh you got me a flag
for the or this is a towel what is this
for the ultimate surfer show on abc
that's that's where i went to school
this is gigantic what yeah
well you know my magic trick it just
keeps there's more fabric yeah my school
goes big man what can i say
the ultimate surfer on
abc the hell [ __ ] big is this thing
what is this a bed sheet